[Música]
[Aplausos]
aprenda a estar aqui diz dentro primeiro
canção que vamos ao povo
joe a arma chave que combina a cidade de lá
Muitos outros
[Música]
para mim
Oh
[Música]
m
hoje
[Música]
foi feito errado
d
em 3 distante
S
[Música]
da minha vida
n
existir
[Música]
em fim
Onde
[Música]
Boa
opa
[Música]
Boa
a mim
E hoje em dia
[Música]
mais
eles são como pimenta
não
seus pisos
às vezes eu piso
eu ouvi sentir
[Música]
triste
e ainda por cima eles me fodem
com minha coleção
[Música]
não
para todo sempre
[Música]
e sim
e sorte
é
ferreiro
[Música]
em fim
para mim
onde está
[Música]
[Aplausos]
está bem
e bonito
para mim
eu vendi
[Música]
mais
sim
E hoje em dia
[Música]
Oh
com
Boa
[Música]
a mesma música charles smile
chapolim eu sou
[Música]
quando há verdade e pule agora
mergulho sim
eu sou fácil
eu sou e quando tudo de mim não é nada
quando nada
é esta
eu sou um caçador
[Música]
sou
quando você olha
me sentiria
[Música]
o jarro e
Eu sou sua nota que você é tudo
[Música]
ef
e tal
para a nação
ao falar
[Música]
a lã
alma
qualquer
[Música]
p
príncipe hide é dizer 20 para todos
mundo vamos cantar o novo
cesta
pare papai agora
chorar pai pai
mas a força
[Música]
sintomas e estamos no Panamá
vocês
[Música]
e abril passado
se você abrir seu coração e estudar
à lua parar parar parar parar
parar um para parar para parar
mas não
mais deles e melhor ação
sim
e se isso acontecer
[Música]
se nós abrimos
para uma parada aqui
[Música]
o mar
S
e soria
[Música]
[Aplausos]